you're what's up guys is prestige here
and what you can climb that that's
dangerous whats up guys its prestige
here and we are deep within my mind's
not really that deep we're just in my
minds and block these off and the we are
ago i'm showing you guys the small of
this mob this mob is the the road to
tick this is what spa drops diamonds
when you kill them or can drop diamonds
on you kill them you see over there that
is an enthralled drama krix now he is ah
he's like the most deadly mod I've seen
mob I've seen um ah crap crap go away go
away go away don't like see I should be
able to take him from here since he
obviously is bigger than one high but he
definitely he kills me in like two hits
when I have this armor on so he's
someone who's to be knocked out with
lately he should be dead soon though
there we go and he dropped he can drop
shards uh corrupted charts okay let's
charge into that way too fast okay there
we go now you see i have three down so
actually that wasn't that much from
three of them but ah let's regain some
hell
and I can turn the sound back up no I
was hearing a cave crawler yeah that
noise let's go check over here dude dude
oh yeah there we go there is come over
your little buddy actually he sounds a
bit different I got another one over
there we can get any real of my ingots
from him oh we got two and i'm on allied
so we'll go take this guy and hello
everybody this should be the hope this
should be the second death this should
be the second episode all cake pops
there should be the second episode of my
new series i think i've decided to go
with the name divine a survival because
i'm using divine RPG so when i call it
divine survival I just figure that I
went well together so that's the name
this is gonna probably going to be a
second episodes and they said i would
last episode i would start it and i
would come with a name and I just
thought divine our divine it would be
good so yeah I can't get a hit off in
this one make sure you hit me ow
front of you that are new to this series
hello take my sexy armor i'm using a mod
called divine RPG mod and it basically
just makes it a divine RPG yeah cuz it
adds tons of Simon's like it adds tons
of uh it adds tons I let me see tons one
more time tons of mobs and ores and
dimensions it's like huh and stop so
it's a really cool mod and I high Lee
just getting it to anybody II was
thinking about it because it's for you
like most mugs at my graph are now I was
trying to think there's really just so
much we can do I don't know what to do
first to eventually get into the next
into the first dimension you need divine
shards which yeah and divine chards you
need to kill a boss i ah entity boss
that you spawn one can spawn another one
can spawn the overworld but you use
choose to spawn so I'm getting some leg
and sick tani so I don't have a Optifine
so and I'm also rendering videos right
now so that's probably causing a bunch
leg yeah dang it stupid lag man hey stop
it wait
it is quite unprofessional but guys give
me like two seconds
all rights I apologize so more stuff we
got some aquatic pellets and we turned
another one into aquatic ingot when our
last one who spent on that let's throw
down their 16 done it's nice let's do
some Hoenn I really need to organize
this sometime that be that should become
priority let's do some somebody's here
good stuff we're getting some nice leg
oh my gosh this lag is in set is intense
I probably shouldn't be trying to record
Wow rendering but I really wanted to so
I am so they just love playing this it
is like like I want to play more so I do
and I know you guys want me to record so
I I do and I try and record most of the
major stuff I do in this sometimes if
I'll just little stuff I want record it
but I'm trying to get most of the stuff
recorded got a crab tell them to grab
sometimes we get whales that spawn those
sharks you were shut why does your shark
have 800 health that doesn't make sense
whatever shark should not have 800
health that is not okay in my book yeah
so apologies about the lag hey open open
trisha me we really need to organize
this hmm alright you know i'm going to
make another chest separate for oars and
stuff of this sort taking clothes on or
so idea or oars oars oars I can't
anymore okay well let's
Oh once you three that should be enough
for two chests yeah barely enough
alright so we're going to put this I'm
going to do yeah just like that nice and
simple all right Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom yeah
just throwing all the oars in there
that's nor that's an ortho any or type
thing really she also make a food chest
yeah [ __ ] i turn my corrupted charge
and script its stone e so this is kind
of like anything yeah are they need to
organize mouths more sometime oh well
that is a task for another day now what
to do what to do let's I want to start a
cow farm let's start a cow farm so for a
cow farm we're going to need fences
let's try 30 fences for now and we're
going to want to make it a little bit
away from the house so let's make it
right here
so just make it like that out I'll fail
boom o dudududu dudududu detected a yes
looking good size and I'm pretty sure I
just had got half of my Kabbalism so
that should just make it know where it
was made it faster and art we have wheat
so now when you go find cows I saw some
over here before that's like this a bit
yeah so Paul I'm really sorry about the
lag since I it's really annoying me too
but it's like say we look at this we're
going like 20ish frames which is not fun
stuff road is not fun stuff oh yeah one
gallon cactuses because this thing works
on cactuses so like it shoots cactuses
cacti just say oh god I think all the
other catcher broke one sec I'm going to
space you out because you just broke all
my all my stuff yes awesome some of them
carry over here so let's get we in hand
well it's a queen and we're gonna check
their animals mmm be running on tiny
render settings cows I saw the calendar
tree before I was going to sell out here
cow well that's a zombie that's as am
Bambi so I'm barber
where are the cows we want to find the
cows since we want to make the letter 14
Chapman tables ok screw this cows
there's one cow there's bound to be more
follow me I have wheat cow-calf follow
me cows ok they got you and I just need
to get your attention there we go hope
you hurt yourself let's go cows I was
going to be difficult but I will make
you a path do not worry all right down
look at them a note look at my weeds
weeds don't you guys love your weights
cows have weeds weeds there we go that
repair we go come on let's get this
before nighttime up all that I was too
much undermined they've actually
followed okay we have one more he'll
push the hell
come on go good job pushing the hill all
right we're almost to your pen just keep
going i think everyone up even one just
still at nine these whales he's those
whales are vicious a vicious I'll tell
you my mind cows okay we don't want you
to fall in the pit so we're gonna go
around the pit since you people are
stupid hey stupid cows wheat yes no wait
wait wait wait do you want this let's go
I don't understand the attraction
physics of this game and understandable
no no no okay come on come on you dumb
cow you who you want wheat oh my gosh
there we go come on
look at all the weed over there oh my
gosh come on let's go oh that one isn't
even attracted come on Cara mom here oh
my gosh you idiot let's go wheat yes
camera now you can do we're almost there
almost town now get in the stupid cage
come on oh my gosh no get in brilli you
walk out to stand oh my gosh wheats
don't you want this isn't this what you
want
these cows are so amazingly mutton they
dumb okay now go in come on oh my gosh
ok screw you guys there that is that
better really you have wheat don't you
people of the width your luck your King
has wheat for you yes that works your
King has wheat for you okay come on okay
okay now screw you guys I just did that
because i'm going to replace it with
some wood now i'll replace with Kabul
what
what all right now make sweet love there
we go awesome just great guys I have
some ladders so I can put that on next
time I show up I can put the lap is on
there how long has this been going it's
a good check okay 15 minutes all right
it looks like the video well we got a
little we got a little action down there
we did some some cool organization we
went and got some cows I was basically
it do anything else well thanks so we
renamed the series that was it said I'm
buddy down here I was hoping for
something something to have spawned in
that spawning room all right guys well I
hope you enjoyed my name is prestige if
you did you've got this far Lyra like
comment rate subscribe my armor is
amazing oh my gosh on king here burn um
yeah he's up